Hotels.ng is an online
hotel booking portal,
and right now we're the
biggest online hotel booking
portal in Nigeria.
Our technology is a little
bit different from that that
is used by the major traveling
sites like Booking.com
and so on, in that we
often have to back up
or bookings using phone
or SMS or WhatsApp.
So when a booking
arrives on our platform
we do not always have a
direct software connection
to the hotel.
So maybe it will
fall back, and then
now become a phone booking that
will take maybe 10, 15 minutes
to fulfill.
So initially, many of those
things we did not see them.
We did not know we'd need
to do it a certain way.
We basically started the
platform and then somebody
would book.
We'd meet a particular
problem, then
we'd rush, develop it,
get it done, release it,
and then it would start working.
So our current
platform is basically
the evolution of everything
that we have learned.
So it was influenced and
guided by the problems
that we had to solve
all along the way.
I think we are a
little bit lucky
in that the industry
that we are in
is something that people very
readily and easily understand.
From the very first
day we went online,
people already started
booking the hotels.
We did not have to really
go out and teach them how
to book hotels.
A lot of people knew this
already from other countries.
And the hotel managers also
have been running such a system
locally.
So taxi drivers
who pick up people,
bring people to their
hotels, and they'd
pay them some kind
of commission.
So they already knew
about commission systems
and all that.
So all we basically had
to go and explain to them
we are going to deliver
you more customers,
and in exchange for that
you pay us a commission.
And they say fine,
well, no problem.
If you can do that, go ahead.
And we would actually do it.
And the same thing
with the customers.
We just said, OK, you can
now book your hotels online,
and they said, that's a very
nice service, let me try it,
and it works.
So I think the early
days for us were not
as difficult as the early
days from some other business,
because we are actually in a
market where there is demand.
But nobody wanted
to spend that money
and go through that effort
of actually going out
to get all those hotels.
I would say a lot
of people do not--
the things that are
holding people back,
I think at the moment,
are that they do not
have an effective way of
distributing their ideas.
So if they actually
develop something
and it's a working
software project,
the sales process is extremely
expensive in Nigeria,
because of how disconnected all
the towns are from each other
and how you would go
about making sales.
So effective software
projects that require sales
are a bit too difficult
to do, actually.
And when it comes to being
able to distribute it
on a global scale, and
reaching other people,
it's difficult for an average
Nigerian developer compete
with a developer in
Romania or in the US,
because there are some
disadvantages that they
have got here.
They don't how steady lights.
They don't have good internet.
So just projects that
are only software based,
they already start
off at a disadvantage.
So it becomes only the very best
that can actually break out.
Those that are
better than average
have got competition that are
also-- a lot of competition
that are also
better than average,
but have got other advantages
that they don't have,
like just having
constant electricity
or having working internet.
I think there are
options available,
but they are definitely much
worse than the options that
are available in other
continents, I'd say.
The availability of finance
for African startups
is quite limited.
Every now and then
there are companies
that come in and throw
a lot of money around
and then they leave, and then
in those spells in between,
there's just not a lot
of capital available.
And that's why I think-- that's
what ties into my earlier
question, which is basically
that companies that do not
operate at losses have the
ability to kind of wait out
the long periods between when
companies are available that
are actually putting
money in Africa.
Because that's
how it looks like.
There are companies that
would, for a long time there
will be no finance available,
and then a few companies will
come in, have a lot
of finance available,
and then they'll
go again after they
have done their
investments in Africa.
So there is money,
but it's seasonal.